une solidarité en béton a lieu dans les
hauteurs de terville liliane prépare les
victuailles pour des convives
particulier l'entrée de préparer le
petit m'anime pour aujourd'hui
[Musique]
pourtant servi avant ça un gros chantier
attend ses petites mains la structure
surmonté de parpaings et déjà ferraillé
ces sommes aujourd'hui vont réaliser un
coulage
il leur faut calibrer le béton c'est
donc trouver les bons dosages avec le
ciment le sable et l'eau ils donnent de
leur temps gratuitement pour venir en
aide à une famille bravo c'est mon moral
est bon le rapport ou demain dès
maintenant voter soit font la démarche
et des bouquets des voix leur ami jean
l'humanité ce problème au mieux durant
les coins sam aura face à lui très
important c'est pour abbas et comme on
abat familiaux mais face à sam on est
maman de malaise
mon rôle est même allé à mon rôle est
monde a souffert alors que se pose à mon
pote décision temps là ils construisent
une rampe d'accès pour personnes
handicapées initiative est louable pour
gerani car depuis deux mois il lui est
impossible de sortir de chez elle
le cabinet pour moi merci beaucoup
c'est parce que énergique et yapo
plusieurs fois dans le dos ça y est
tombé mais à bon dieu jamais ni jamais
il aura fallu deux mètres cubes de béton
environ 5000 euros de dons et plusieurs
bras pour réaliser cette trempe
parmi eux des experts en maçonnerie en
sacré coup de main une tradition de
moins en moins pratiquée il faut la
faire perdurer parce que ça devient de
plus en plus difficile pour les
personnes âgées
je vais dire la situation qu'ils qu'ils
ont et vu la conjoncture aussi
rien n'est donné tout est cher et et
ils ont pas beaucoup pour s'en sortir
nous sommes obligés de les aider après
l'effort un réconfortant repas
traditionnel du macadam une pause
gourmande avant le prochain coup de main
à schoelcher prévu dans deux semaines